[Música]
llevo 30 años viajando y explorando
colombia fotografiando la documentando
la he tenido el enorme privilegio de
estar en lugares donde casi nadie ha
estado
para mí ha sido un verdadero honor estar
en algunos de esos lugares pero siento
que a veces los colombianos no
entendemos en profundidad el enorme
valor que tienen esos ecosistemas no
solamente para los colombianos sino para
el mundo entero
muchos de esos lugares permanecen sin
estudiar sin explorar debidamente o
algunos lugares han sido explorados
tímidamente les quiero mostrar tres de
esos lugares
en la cuenca alta y media de los ríos
cajambre y tapaje en la vertiente
occidental de la cordillera occidental
prácticamente no sabemos nada de la
fauna y flora que allí está lo mismo
ocurre en la amazonía colombiana en el
río apaporis y en el río pure y más de
lo mismo ocurre en la región comprendida
entre los ríos y ari y cagüán
entonces la pregunta que les quiero
hacer es cómo vamos a cuidar un
territorio que no conocemos
mientras pasan estos 18 minutos de
charla vamos a destruir 5 hectáreas de
bosque amazónico y otras 5 de bosque
natural colombiano
seguramente estamos destruyendo
ecosistemas que contienen especies que
ni siquiera el mundo sabe
en los últimos 25 años los colombianos
hemos destruido 6 millones 400 mil
hectáreas solamente para tener una
comparación de qué significa ese
territorio es exactamente equivalente al
territorio de un país como lituania en
comparación
panamá tiene 7.5 millones de hectáreas
es decir hemos destruido en el último
cuarto de siglo
casi un panamá completo
trescientos y trescientos mil hectáreas
en el último año
este mono que es el tipi del caquetá se
descubrió en el año 2010 y paso de
descubierto a críticamente amenazado
según la 15 en la unión internacional
para la conservación de la naturaleza
en 8 años 8 años prácticamente acabamos
con esta especie
esta especie no solamente tiene la
particularidad de vivir en esa porción
del caquetá es endémico de caquetá es
endémico de colombia pero además por
estos días tiene una característica que
ya casi ninguno de nosotros tenemos
particularmente los milenios y es
conservan su pareja durante toda la vida
no todas son malas noticias
este personaje que ven aquí fue
descubierto tan solo hace cinco años en
agosto del 2000
15 este mamífero se descubrió en los
pelos
el bosque de niebla de los andes
colombianos
hace 35 años no ocurría algo de esta
naturaleza eso es parte de lo que
esconde este país de los secretos que
hay bajo la selva de las cosas que están
por estudiar de las cosas que
necesitamos entre todos colaborar y
encontrar un mecanismo para entender
nuestro territorio el cine es
ciertamente una avenida para eso es una
avenida para descubrir es una avenida
para informar
y en este año en el año 2009 5 de junio
en particular ocurrió una cosa muy
interesante en el cine mundial y es
luc bessón y yann arthus bertrand
productores ejecutivos de esta película
maravillosa llamada home lograron hacer
en simultánea un lanzamiento en cine
televisión bluray dividís e internet
todo el mismo día ese mismo día en una
sola plataforma de internet como es
youtube que tenía para ese entonces sólo
cuatro años se reprodujeron 400 mil
veces este esta pieza
hoy sería un dato asombroso pero en ese
momento cuando youtube estaba apenas
naciendo lo era aún más esta película
narra la biodiversidad del planeta pero
además cuenta cómo la humanidad está
transformando el balance de ese planeta
de este planeta
este hecho además de que colombia que
está incluida en la lista de los
llamados países megadiversos aquellos
que contienen la mayor biodiversidad por
área no incluyo a colombia
entonces ese hecho sumado al amor
profundo que tengo por colombia a mi
pasión por la fotografía sirvieron de
inspiración para enfrentar un proyecto
para empezar un proyecto cinematográfico
de la naturaleza de colombia magia
salvaje cuyo objetivo fundamental era
generar el amor despertar el amor por un
país por un territorio como el
colombiano
pero pronto me di cuenta que abrazar un
proyecto de esta naturaleza no era
posible si no formábamos y colaboramos
con un equipo altamente talentoso
comprometido con ese objetivo y de gente
que realmente estuviera durante los seis
años que duró esta producción al frente
y estando todo el tiempo juntos y todo
el tiempo con comprometidos con el
proyecto como por ejemplo andrea mi
esposa que está aquí entre el público
una cantidad de gente que colaboró con
que este resultado se diera y el segundo
objetivo era hacer uso intensivo de la
última tecnología cinematográfica
disponible para lograr o intentar
entender profundamente lo que pasaba con
el comportamiento de ciertas especies en
colombia les quiero mostrar tres
ejemplos de cosas que la tecnología
permitió descubrir además de simplemente
capturar las imágenes utilizamos una
cámara llamada phantom que es una cámara
de ultra alta velocidad esta cámara
puede filmar a 25.000 cuadros por
segundo el mejor celular de esta sala
hoy seguramente lo hacen 960 y es un muy
buen slow motion esta cámara 25 mil
cuadros por segundo puede tener
prácticamente cualquier movimiento en la
misma cámara que se usa para ver cómo
sale un proyectil de un arma
el colibrí es un ave que todos tenemos
en el imaginario como un ave pierna
esbelta graciosa no obstante descubrimos
y descubrieron los científicos gracias a
esto que el que vivir y puede tener un
comportamiento bastante más violento de
lo que nos imaginamos veamos
un segundo ejemplo
es esta especie que ven aquí es el
caimán llanero que no es un caimán es un
poco del hilo pero todo el cordón de los
llamados por nombres diferentes este es
el famoso cocodrilo intermedios una
especie propia de la cuenca del río
orinoco solo presente en colombia y
venezuela
el proceso de apareamiento de esta
especie sólo se da en la noche entonces
necesitábamos una cámara que realmente
pudiera captar la imagen en la noche lo
hicimos con una cámara que se llama
starlight que como su nombre nos sugiere
es una cámara que puede filmar con la
luz de una estrella tan literalmente lo
hace en la oscuridad pero la gracia
realmente fue más allá la gracia de esta
escena es que los científicos lograron
hacer una observación nuestro amigo
rafael antelo y doctor en cocodrilo
hinojo el único que hay en el mundo
perteneciente a la fundación palmarito
logró observar que el comportamiento de
cuidado de los recién nacidos no era
solamente
propio de la de la hembra que también el
macho podía cuidar a los recién nacidos
de una observación que está hoy
documentada
en papers científicos y que se hizo
gracias a esta producción de apps
luego de esto el macho lleva a su cría a
una cueva para que crezca sin problema
es este complemento solo lo tenía la
hembra y finalmente un tercer ejemplo es
la utilización de la cara de la cámara
más estabilizada que existía en el
momento y que aún existe se llama
cineflex y trajimos a roncha por uno de
los mejores cinematógrafos aéreos que
existen que ha trabajado con discovery
con nadie consigue es conseguir en
attenberg es una persona que realmente
se enamoró de colombia de ver que en tan
sólo una hora podía encontrar todos los
climas y una gran cantidad de vegetación
que él no se imaginaba que podría haber
en tan corto tiempo esta tecnología nos
permitió volar sobre los picos nevados
nos permitió volar sobre algunas de las
islas colombianas sobre muchos lugares
que de otra manera no hubiéramos
capturado no obstante la película es tan
solo una puerta o sea no pretendíamos y
obviamente en una hora no podríamos
cubrir todo el país el país
quería hacer 23 maya salvajes o hasta 5
si fuera necesario por eso la pregunta
que continuamos haciéndonos es cómo
hacemos para acelerar el ritmo de
conocer nuestros ecosistemas y la
respuesta en ese momento puede hacer una
publicación que contemplará los 100
sitios de colombia que todos los
colombianos deberíamos conocer y saber y
por lo menos poder ver la descripción de
ellos así volamos en sitios como la
sierra de nada de santa marta
esta foto que ven aquí son los dos picos
o los dos accidentes más altos de
colombia el pico colon y el pico bolívar
no solamente importantes desde el punto
de vista estético sino por las
comunidades que allí habitan y
obviamente por el ciclo del agua
sin embargo explorar también conlleva
una profunda responsabilidad sobre todo
con las comunidades que allí habitan
esta comunidad que vive en la sierra
nevada de santa marta que vive casi el
aislamiento voluntario les prometimos
que jamás revelaría mos su localización
geográfica al igual que una de sus
lagunas más sagradas
esta comunidad realmente ha entendido
que en conocer su territorio estudiar
íntimamente su territorio lo han hecho a
su modo pero realmente producen los
beneficios que es viven verdaderamente
en una sociedad sostenible
sin embargo nuestros investigadores y
nuestros científicos necesitan más
acceso a nuestros parques naturales
guardan un sinnúmero de secretos
necesitamos unir a los científicos a la
academia a las organizaciones
gubernamentales a la empresa privada
para entender mejor este territorio y
poderlo preservar y como hablar de
preservación sin mencionar el parque
nacional chiribiquete parque nacional
chiribiquete es el área más protegida
más grande de colombia con más de 4
millones de hectáreas
acaba de entrar en la lista de
patrimonio mixto de la unesco
muchas
inscripciones o arte rupestre ha sido
encontrado allí del cual hoy sabemos muy
poco sabemos muy poco de la
biodiversidad que hay aquí en una
exploración de tres noches
olga huertas del museo de historia
natural de londres encontró 30 especies
30 que ella jamás había visto y de la
persona que más mariposas ha visto en el
planeta es un sitio realmente
maravilloso pero las amenazas no son
pocas hoy hay reportes de a menos de 9
kilómetros hay deforestación en la
frontera del parque ya no solamente en
la zona de amortiguación es un sitio que
realmente merece ser estudiado y está
siendo degradado si observan en esta
gráfica abajo van a ver que los
elementos el agua el viento está
haciendo está ya produciendo efectos
sobre estas pinturas y he traído a
colación esta en particular porque de
acuerdo al profesor urbina fernando
urbina de la universidad nacional y
filósofo tal vez la persona que más
pinturas ha estudiado en la amazonía
colombiana él dice que quizás estas
pinturas
en contra de todo lo que la gente piensa
lo que los científicos han pensado hasta
el momento no necesariamente fueron
hechas por los cars y jonás que habitan
en esta zona sino que quizás también
pudieron ser hechas por otro tipo de
culturas y más interesante es que esta
pintura que tuvimos la oportunidad de
registrar por primera vez después de
leer unos escritos de el etnobotánico
richard evans schultes es una de las
únicas que tiene un indígena en posición
sedente en posición sentada
hay mucho que estudiar aquí hay mucho
que no conocemos no tenemos tiempo que
perder necesitamos acelerar el estudio
la comprensión de nuestro territorio la
propuesta que yo quiero hacer hoy es por
un lado el uso intensivo de tecnología y
por otro la colaboración entre todas
estas organizaciones que tienen la
posibilidad eso es lo que está haciendo
o están haciendo algunos científicos en
el mundo como por ejemplo con el uso de
tecnología light
con el uso de esta tecnología líder que
no es otra cosa que el uso de rayos de
luz que desde una plataforma como un
helicóptero un avión bajan a la
superficie de la tierra rebotan y
entendemos cuál es la distancia se
pueden hacer modelos de superficie
perfectamente precisos y así aparecieron
más de 40.000 estructuras nuevas en
tikal lo propio pasó en angamos mexico
una investigación dirigida por el doctor
kris fiche arqueólogo moderno de la
universidad de colorado y quien ha
empleado esta tecnología con mucho éxito
lo que ven aquí a mano izquierda de sus
pantallas es cómo se ve hoy de campo
cómo se vería desde el aire y la mano
derecha lo que había permanecido oculto
durante ciclos y hoy entienden o
entendemos la cantidad de caminos y
estructuras nuevas que esta tecnología
puede brindarnos esta fotografía la
primera vez que la muestra un público
corresponde a la región de la mojana en
el caribe colombiano en la mojana se
asentaron los zenúes una de las culturas
que desarrollaron la mayor obra de
ingeniería hidráulica que se tiene
noticia en el continente americano
lograron entender los ciclos del agua
lograron hacer terrazas
que irriga van en épocas de sequía y
desalojado en el agua en época de
invierno algo que la ingeniería hoy no
ha sido capaz de hacer algo que hacemos
con diques que se rompen los senos
desarrollaron esa tecnología y probó
durante muchísimos años porque se
asentaron
mil años antes de cristo y duraron casi
1000 de nuestra era edad durante 2000
años desarrollaron este tema hoy en
armonía con fernando montejo del
distrito colombiano de antropología
historia
estamos aplicando la tecnología líder
para entender que había allí de las 500
mil hectáreas hoy solamente quedan 9 mil
no tenemos tiempo que perder necesitamos
en terminar de entender este territorio
necesitamos organizar de nuevo
organizaciones de gobierno la academia
los estudiantes la empresa privada para
entender nuestro territorio acompáñenme
a redescubrir esta colombia profunda no
solamente para entenderla a nosotros
sino para que el mundo entienda la
importancia que tiene este territorio
para nuestra subsistencia y la
subsistencia de todos
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]